one should be satisfied with the fact
that we have achieved what we have
achieved it's not nothing hi there steve
coffin here
today i want to talk about
perfectionism in language learning if
you enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast
service please leave a comment i do
appreciate it
now what do i mean by perfectionism
i think i i could also term
perfectionism and language learning the
sort of the desire to perform how did i
do
i've compared that urge to
sort of be judged or the fear to be
judged it's sort of like an olympic
diver and to me language learning is
very different from olympic diving or
any kind of performance sport
we learn languages in order to
communicate
so this might mean in order to
understand a movie
in order to watch a series on netflix
and get a sense of
some maybe distorted sense of the
culture but nevertheless to enjoy that
experience to understand and also to
communicate to speak
communicate ideas communicate
feelings
it's all about communication
so now of course we would all like to
speak
you know as well as we can
as correctly as we can
and to that extent it is useful to
every now and again study grammar
uh because there are things when we just
listen and read that we don't notice in
the language i've said this before some
things have to be pointed out to us and
even after they're pointed out to us we
still won't get them right i mean again
we've had this experience
of correcting a mistake and making the
same mistake again and again and again
and and the reason that happens is
because in my mind the process of
learning a language
is a process of
creating new
neural connections in the brain
uh the brain establishing some patterns
us slowly getting used to this new
language
but we get used to it or we get
accustomed to it
in a very individual way it's very much
influenced by our native language
and so
some people are going to
you know
acquire a
series of habits in the language that
might be
with better pronunciation or worse
pronunciation
or
more grammatically correct or less
grammatically correct while we want to
get better we shouldn't be so worried
about how we're doing
worried about how we're being judged
that we miss the main goal which is
communication
uh and and i the reason i bring this up
right now because
on uh amongst the comments here someone
said oh steve you know in fact i get
this quite often you say you speak 20
languages in fact you don't the other
day you spoke italian and you were very
rusty and so forth and so on
true and there are languages that i have
spoken and i would have trouble speaking
right now at least initially
but those are still languages that i
have invested a lot of time into
learning
those are languages like say korean
where i'm not at all happy at my ability
to produce the language or even to
understand the language i have at least
on our account and link a large
passive vocabulary i understand how the
language works the structures in the
language because i've seen these
patterns so many many times but i
haven't been using it and therefore i
can't speak it very well if at all
well i can speak it but not very well
and but if i were to go to korea it
wouldn't take me a day or two before i
would be able to speak fairly well when
i was in greece or prague or romania i
was also communicating communicating not
perfectly but communicating so
languages that we learn
to a degree which is less than perfect
those are still languages that we have
learned to some extent we have enjoyed
learning we have discovered bits of and
if that is true for languages that i
don't speak as well as i would like
say italian which might be my tenth
language
it's also true for someone who is
learning
their first foreign language in other
words it's always not quite as good as
we would like
however it's very much a personal thing
it's your
foreign language it's your english it's
your italian it's your spanish
and
one should be satisfied with the fact
that we have achieved what we have
achieved it's not nothing even though we
would all like to improve
and and that's another reason why and
we've had this debate before here about
pitch accent in japanese
i lived in japan for nine years i've
been speaking japanese for
40 50 years
never even knew until recently that
there was such a thing as pitch accent
it never prevented me from communicating
i do not believe the japanese people by
and large are bothered by someone who
has
improper pitch accent whatever that
might mean
we don't need to seek perfection we
don't need to there's nothing wrong
with aspiring to achieve perfection
there's nothing wrong with focusing on
one language and trying to be as
accurate with the grammar as possible
trying to get pitch accent right in
japanese and all these other things
but it's not necessary and if you don't
do those things you can still
enjoy the language you can still say you
speak the language because
you know performing to a degree of
perfection
is a very limited aspect of what's
involved in learning a language
and i think to the extent that people
are concerned about nailing these things
down
it probably inhibits them
and it reduces the enjoyment of language
learning
it makes us less likely to engage with
the language
to speak the language
and we all know that the more we engage
the with the language the more we listen
the more we read the more we speak the
more we make mistakes
the more we're going to improve in time
so
i just mentioned that because people
often say well you say speak 20 like you
say you speak 20 languages but you're
not very good in any of them and yeah
i'm not going to be as good in 20
languages as someone who focuses on one
and there's always people who are better
than me better than you
it doesn't matter it doesn't take away
from the enjoyment that we can all
achieve in learning one or more foreign
language so that's what i have to say
about the pursuit of perfectionism
thank you for listening